today is the day my brand-new book the
right side of history is out plus baito
embraces third trimester abortion and
Vladimir Putin cracks down on the news
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
okay so I really want to talk to you
about my new book which I think is you
know I'm biased I think it's important I
think it's good and I think that you
should read it
but again I'm very biased on this
subject I'll get to my new book plus I
want to talk about bado and I want to
talk about Andrew yang who is now making
headlines for some good reasons and some
not-so-great reasons we'll get to all of
that in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that for decades credit
cards have been telling us to buy it now
and pay for it later with interest
despite your best intentions intentions
that interest can get out of control
really quickly with Lending Club you can
consolidate your debt or pay off credit
cards with one fixed monthly payment
since 2007 Lending Club has helped
millions of people regain control of
their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to a
bank no high interest credit cards just
go to Lending Club com tell them about
yourself
and how much you want to borrow pick the
terms that are right for you and if
you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued just
go to Lending Club com /ban this Lending
Club com /ban check your rate in minutes
you can borrow up to $40,000 that is
Lending Club com /ban once more Lending
Club com /ban all loans made by web bank
member FDIC Equal Housing lender there's
no reason for you to live with that
piling up interest rate on the credit
card instead consolidate that that do
the responsible thing be financially
independent go check out Lending Club
com /ban check your eight minutes borrow
up to 40 grand Lending Club com / bento
check them out right now okay so today
is the day my new book release which I
am very excited about we've been talking
about it for a while here on the program
but I wanted to tell you what I think in
general the book is about it's called
the right side of history don't worry
we're gonna get to the news as well but
this is tied in to the news because the
reality is that there is a great
question right now in the West in
Western civilization and it's tearing us
apart and that is what is Western
civilization what is it on the one side
you have a bunch of people who say
Western civilization is terrible no good
very bad on the other side you have a
bunch of people who say that Western
civilization is wonderful but completely
mystifying it so I think that here's the
truth all of the good things that are
around you democracy liberalism free
speech prosperity science
all of these things are the outgrowth of
a civilization in which you live and
whose values you have embedded in your
system whether you like it or not but
it's it's fascinating to see how people
really don't know much about the roots
of the civilization that has led them to
these critiques of the civilization or
to a defense of something that is not
Western civilization I'll tell you what
I mean
so the manifesto of the New Zealand
shooter is of course a deeply evil
document and that is not a shock because
this is a deeply evil white supremacist
but the guy references the West many
times throughout this document what
exactly did he mean by the West well he
meant racial superiority of white people
in the document which you should not
read I've not encouraged people to read
it the only reason that I even mentioned
the document now is because I think it
is important to rebut what is a
widespread perception about what exactly
this evil white supremacist thought and
with whom he sympathized he talks about
the West a lot in this document and
people on the Left say ah see he's just
defending Western civilization Western
civilization is bad no that's not the
way this works when this shooter talks
about the West he met racial superior
superiority of white people he
explicitly divides quote the myth of the
individual and the sovereignty of
private property so this is not someone
who is standing for life liberty and
property in the Lockean formation he
spits at democracy
he says the Christianity is weak he
scoffs at capitalism he tears into
conservatism he says that conservatism
had surrendered to the myth of the
individual and the sovereignty of
private property
unfortunately that view of the West that
the West is basically a hierarchy of
racial power and that we have created
all of these concepts in order to excuse
that racial hierarchy that is not
restricted to the views of white
supremacists unfortunately there's an
intersectional Theory Club and these
people believe a lot of folks on the
political left believe that when we say
Western civilization we mean the same
thing as this white supremacist Western
civilization is really just a way for
white people to cram down their power on
other folks this is why you had folks
like Jesse Jackson in the 1980s leading
chance at UC Berkeley hey hey ho ho
Western Civ has got to go the idea being
that Western civilization was truly just
a hierarchy of power established by
white supremacists and on the other hand
you avoid some premises saying that the
West is basically a hierarchy of power
established
white supremacists that is not true that
is not true Western civilization is a
set of ideas it was always a set of
ideas now where those ideas always
perfectly realized of course not in the
same way that the ideas of the
Declaration of Independence were not
properly realized and took hundreds of
years to come to full fruition the
notion that all men are created equal
encompassing people of all different
races for example that took a century to
actually come to fruition two centuries
if you count Jim Crow obviously the fact
is that an eternal good principle does
not mean that it is properly it is
properly acted upon over the great span
of time but the principles that
undergird the West are the principles
that undergird all of the things that
you like the iPhone in your hand from
the iPhone in your hands to the concept
of democracy so what exactly is the West
well I think that what the West really
is what the West really is is a
combination of judeo-christian values
and Greek reason and these two things
are in tension they're always in tension
reason and revelation the idea that
there is a God and that God runs the
universe and that there's an objective
morality that of course is in tension
with the the part of us that's
reasonable that says okay well you know
I don't see this God where does his
morality come from and these two things
are constantly vying with each other for
power the problem is when you get rid of
one of them when you get rid of
judeo-christian values for example you
end up with secular tyranny and when you
get rid of secular reason you end up
with religious tyranny the the building
of these values is a long three thousand
year story and because we have lost the
values that we share because we have
decided to see each other as either
representatives of the hierarchy or
people fighting against Western
civilization or angrier at each other
than ever we've lost a sense of common
meaning and common purpose we've lost a
sense of individual meaning and
individual purpose polls show that we
are angrier at each other than we have
been in a very long time the average
trust in key institutions in the United
States is down to 32% that's not trust
in the Democratic Party or the
Republican Party that's trust in your
local school that's trust in your police
forces only 31% of Americans today think
that most people that they live with can
be trusted
Mansa that's a shocking statement 52% of
Americans
only say they trust most or all of their
neighbors which means that half of
Americans don't trust most or all of
their neighbors then even know their
neighbors 80% of Americans buy polling
data say America is more divided today
than ever which of course is untrue we
fought a civil war in this country and
we also had the 1960s the most divisive
time in modern American history suicide
rates are up the opioid epidemic is
taking additional lives we've had the
first downturn in life expectancy in the
United States in decades and that is due
to a crisis of meaning so where is that
crisis of meaning come from so some
people on sort of the populist right and
the populist left suggest that the the
crisis of meaning is coming from
economics that we've had a bifurcated
economy since the 1980s and since the
1970s and the the rise of globalization
has created a two-tier system in the
United States but the truth is the
poverty spans politics they're they're a
bunch of people who live in the sticks
in Ohio who are not voting the same way
as people living in the inner cities in
Los Angeles this is not about the 1%
versus the 99% and just to be accurate
about this the fact is that 9 since the
1970s the upper-middle class has been
the fastest-growing sector of the
American population and overall we are
all living better economically than we
were in the 1970s because prices have
gone down and we get more stuff for our
dollar now does that mean that everybody
has the same kind of job that they had
in 1950s when you were working on a
construction when you were working on
some sort of assembly line for 30 years
and then getting a gold watch at the end
no it doesn't but the truth is you
wouldn't want to work those jobs the
fact is that those jobs are better done
by machines we have the most booming
economy in American history at this
point more people employed than any time
in American history and yet we are still
at each other's throats you know a lot
of folks who think that it's racial
divides but why exactly should racial
divides have cropped up again now the
fact is that we are more racially equal
than any Society in human history in
1958 only 4% of Americans said that they
were fine with black/white intermarriage
that stat was 87 percent by 2013 as of
2013 72 percent of white Americans and
66 percent of black Americans thought
race relations in the United States were
good as of July 2016 before Trump's
election that number was down to 53% of
Americans overall why is this happening
why
reversing course when it comes to racial
politics how about technology so some
people say it's social media that's
making things worse
I agree that social media is making
things worse it does feed an outrage
cycle you look for stories that that
fulfill your confirmation bias but that
is a means not a reason meaning it
amplifies but it's not the rationale for
the amplification in the first place
social media is a great way of spreading
misinformation and division but there
has to be a desire to do that in the
first place we're not happy as a society
or at least our level of happiness has
radically decreased in the freest most
civilized society in human history so
what exactly can restore happiness first
we have to go back to the original
definition of happiness what is it that
makes us happy in the first place we've
mixed up temporary joy for happiness
we've mixed up sensory experience for
happiness we've mixed up the idea of
material prosperity for happiness these
are not happiness all of the ancients
whether you're talking about
judeo-christian values or Greek
philosophers all of them believed that
happiness had to do with a sense of
moral purpose in the Bible the word for
happiness is simcha in the in the Hebrew
Bible and simcha essentially means right
action in accordance with God's will
because God actually commands people to
be be' simcha to actually be happy well
how can I command you to be happy how
can I command you to an emotion the idea
in Judaism is that you cultivate the
emotion by action by right action in
accordance with virtue by doing that you
cultivate a lifestyle where you live the
simcha in happiness in accordance with
what God wants of you and this is true
in Christianity as well true happiness
lies in doing what God wants of you in
Greek theory there's something very
similar going on Aristotle's eudaimonia
being active in accord with complete
virtue he defines X be it being happy is
acting in accordance with right reason
over the course of your life so acting
with purpose acting with meaning acting
with reason so what do we need to
achieve that kind of purpose and
happiness what do we need you to make
society and ourselves happier I think we
need four things I think we need four
things and one second I'll tell you what
are the four things I think you need a
lot of this is in my book the right side
of history out today first let's talk
about how you can make your business
better hi
is challenging but there's one place
that you can go where hiring is actually
pretty simple fast and smart it's a
place where growing businesses connect
to qualified candidates that place is
zip recruiters calm daily wire zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with our powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and then invites
them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match
zip recruiter is so effective that 80%
of employers who post on zip recruiter
can equality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try super cooter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that's
zip recruiter dot-com slash daily Wire
Dai ly WI re zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire and again you're
gonna save yourself time you're gonna
save yourself money instead of posting
on 1,000 job boards the possible
employees come to you check them out
right now for free at SIP recruiter comm
slash daily wire the smartest way to
hire ok so what do we need to achieve
happiness I think there are four
elements individual purpose individual
capacity communal purpose communal
capacity see we as human beings exist on
two planes on the one side we are
individuals we want to be alone with our
families want to be left alone to make
our own decisions and on the other hand
human beings are naturally political and
social creatures we want to be with
other people we want to build a social
fabric we want to build something
together now if you move too far in one
direction in the individual direction
then the social fabric crumbles and you
end up with this sort of dog-eat-dog
individualism where we're not helping
each other out where we don't care about
each other and then usually people ask
for some sort of overarching government
in order to force people to care for
each other
and that's bad on the other hand if you
stretch too far in the communal
direction and you forget about the
individual then the individual gets
crushed because the idea is that the
interests of the community outweigh the
interests of the individual this is sort
of the French revolutionary idea that
rights spring from government and
therefore government can activate si as
a body moving in the communal interest
to crush the individual so we need both
to recognize that human beings exist
simultaneously as individuals and also
as members of a society
as members of Apollo's as members of the
city so we have to have things that
fulfill us both as individuals and as
members of the community we need first
of all individual moral purpose we need
to believe that we have meaning as
individuals that we here have an
identity as individuals that is
meaningful and that our action in the
world is meaningful this comes from the
basic biblical idea that we are all made
in God's image meaning that we all have
a godly mission and God cares about this
and that we are endowed with both rights
and duties our individual moral purpose
lies in using our reason to individually
live up to what God expects of us or
what reason would have us do which in
the religious vision is the same thing
we have to have meaning as individuals
apart from society's demands you're
alone on a desert island what do you do
with your life or the religious answer
is you live in accordance with God's
will and the Aristotelian answer is you
live in accordance with reason and this
is what makes you a virtuous person who
is capable of happiness we also have to
have individual capacity in a second I'm
gonna get to what individual capacity
means so individual capacity means that
we have the capacity for reason then we
have to have the ability to pursue our
goals with some degree of success this
means we have to have free will that we
have the ability to choose otherwise and
it means that we also have to be able to
exercise something magical and mystical
called a reasonable instinct to overcome
our own natural inclinations the
founders were all self-help specialists
and they believed in our capacity to
better ourselves religion is all about
this idea that we have to better
ourselves Viktor Frankl was a Holocaust
survivor wrote in the book man's search
for meaning about living through the
Holocaust quote every day every hour
offered the opportunity to make a
decision a decision which determined
whether you would or would not submit to
those powers which threatened to rob you
of your very self your inner freedom
which determined whether or not you
would become the plaything of
circumstance renouncing freedom and
dignity to become molded into the form
of the typical inmate in other words it
was the capacity to choose that gave us
the meaning you have to you have to
believe that you're here for a reason
and also that you have the ability to
fulfill that reason okay that's as an
individual then we have to have a
communal moral purpose we need a social
fabric the single best predictor of
lifelong happiness according to
longitudinal studies from places like
Harvard is the exist
since of close relationships social
capital shared priorities this is what
binds us together now there's been a lot
of talk about diversity diversity is
great so long as we are all looking in
the same direction diversity is not
great so long as we are all pulling each
other apart this is what Robert Putnam
discovered in writing his book Bowling
Alone Harvard sociologist he said that
the only two things that go up along
with the diversity of a census tract is
tv-watching and protest marches so the
idea that diversity is our strength he
said is not true except when there's a
shared semblance of purpose so inside a
church for example where everybody
shares a purpose to worship God and
commune with God then diversity can be a
great boon because people have different
experiences but they're all aimed in the
right direction the same thing is true
in the army where you see I mean you
speak to people who have been in the
military they have a shared sense of
purpose and all of their individual
differences are secondary to their
communal sense of shared purpose we as a
country have to have that too we as a
nation have to have that and finally we
have to have communal capacity we have
to have strong social institutions
because that allows us to be free as
individuals without empowering the
government to run roughshod over us
Alexis de Tocqueville talks about this
at length and democracy in America he
says what makes America different is
that America has these strong social
institutions he meant mostly churches
and all the founders believe this even
the ones who are deistic or even
atheistic believed that you required a
strong social fabric rooted in
judeo-christian values in order to build
a communal capacity the ability for all
of us to come together and do the things
we need to do while still protecting
each other as individuals so what built
what built our civilization such that we
could fulfill individual purpose
individual capacity communal purpose and
communal capacity the balance between
between judeo-christian ethics and Greek
reason Jerusalem and Athens in the
typical formation Jerusalem the idea of
judeo-christian values brought us the
idea that a masterplan stands behind
everything right though and that we are
capable as human beings of trying to
understand that master plan the idea
that God is moral and demands of us a
morality that we are not supposed to
simply make up our own morality that
gives us a shared sense of meaning and
purpose that history progresses and that
we have a share in building that history
the story of the Bible is God taking a
nation
slavery to freedom and God caring about
the progression of history the Bible
provides us the judeo-christian ethic
provides us with the idea of free choice
that you can choose otherwise okay
that's all important stuff for building
a civilization but it's not enough you
also have to have Athens you have to
have reason you have to believe that
there is a purpose in nature that we can
determine the meaning of things by
looking at them that we can figure out
what is true by studying the universe
this does require the idea of a designer
which is why two mystic thought is
really a merger between Aristotelian
thought and Christianity it's why my
manatee and Moses Maimonides his thought
is very much in the same vein the sort
of merger between Greek reason and
judeo-christian ethics because here's
the thing if you think that you got all
your values from God why why use reason
at all reason becomes something
superfluous but what Aquinas did what
Maimonides did is they said no reason
brings you to the same place that
judeo-christian ethics do and provides
you the impetus for action not only that
reason allows you to build science
because you have to study the universe
in order to understand what is true and
what is good it brings you the birth of
democracy the state is in existence in
order to forward this quest for reason
and in order forward the quest for
reason you actually have to respect the
rights of the individual is why Cicero
was writing about true law is right
reason in agreement with nature they
can't act against natural law this is
the this is what Thomas Jefferson writes
in the Declaration of Independence when
he's talking about natural law when he
says nature and nature's God what he is
talking about is the natural law the
idea that you can look at the universe
around you and discover Tilos purpose in
nature natural law theory is the
foundation of the notion that you have
rights that are independent of
government and that government didn't
create those rights out of nothing
the tension between Jerusalem and Athens
the interplay that is what built the
West that is what built the greatest
civilization in the history of mankind
you abandon judeo-christian values you
abandon free will you abandon purpose
what you end up with is a reversion to
tribalism there were versions who let's
all get together in tribes and beat the
crap out of each other a reversion to
romantic nationalism okay we as a
broader society will run roughshod over
other societies you ends up at
communism we will construct a theory of
morals completely independent of our
judeo-christian roots and then we will
suggest that that system of morals can
run roughshod over the individual forget
about the idea that all individuals are
made in the image of God all individuals
are cogs in a machine you know but
fascism the idea that if you want to
forward the social compact that means
destruction of the weak and finally you
end up where we are right now you end up
with subjectivism the idea that
happiness can't be achieved through any
of these other means that we've been
talking about instead true happiness is
simply self-esteem and if you threaten
my self-esteem you are threatening my
identity and therefore I have no reason
to use it the reason doesn't play a part
here anything you say that I disagree
with is not about a reason discussion
it's about you attacking me that's what
happens when you a man in religion when
you abandon reason you end up with
theocracy you end up with what we've
seen historically in Christian countries
that thousand years ago you end up with
what we see in Pakistan right now or
Afghanistan theocratic systems where
human rights go by the wayside we have
to revisit these roots if we want to
rebuild our civilization that's what my
new book is all about the right side of
history it's on sale today so go check
it out right now I'm speaking about all
of this at the Reagan Library tonight
it's why I believe it's sold out but I'm
speaking a lot more about these things
and these have real relevance to today's
debate if you're not going to defend
Western civilization for what it is then
we are in real trouble we need to
revisit those roots okay in just a
second I'm gonna get to the latest news
from the 2020 race first let's talk
about your sleep quality there's nobody
on the planet like you so why would you
buy a generic mattress built for
everybody else helix sleep has built a
quiz that takes two minutes to complete
they use the answers to match your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress whether you are a side
sleeper or a hot sleeper where they got
a completo firm bed with helix there's
no more guessing and there is no more
confusion just go to helix sleep calm
slash men take their two-minute sleep
quiz they will match you to a mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life for couples helix can even
split the mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
fuel preferences for each side they've
got a ten-year warranty you get to try
it out for 100 nights risk-free right
now helix is offering up to 125 dollars
off all mattress orders get up to 125
bucks off at helix sleep calm slash Ben
that is helix sleep calm slash Ben from
125 dollars off your mattress order
helix sleep comm slash spend my wife and
I have a helix sleep mattress it is
extraordinarily comfortable we did this
two-minute sleep quiz they personalized
the mattress for us is really easy it
just showed up in the mail and we popped
it on the bed frame we were good to go
it's so good I got one for my sister for
her wedding as well check it out helix
sleep comm slash been for up to 125
bucks off your mattress order okay so
meanwhile the 2020 Democrats continue to
move more and more radical they are
moving in more and more radical
directions beta or orc of course leading
the way gotta love yourself some beta so
beta yesterday came out and he basically
embraced late term abortion a position
that is only held by some thirteen
percent of the American public only
thirteen percent of Americans are in
favor of keeping abortion legal past the
20th week bado is one of them because
the Democratic Party has decided to hold
scale embrace abortion at every turn and
turn it into an identity politics issue
that if you don't support abortion up to
a points of birth somehow your
anti-woman bado did this routine he's
got this real weird habit bado does of
going into various institutions public
establishments and then standing on the
counters as though it's Dead Poets
Society and maybe he thinks that it
makes him seem romantic maybe there are
people who find this sort of thing
romantic it's just kind of weird and and
puts me off for sure but you know then
again I'm not a big fan of the of the
air SATs authenticity of a dork
here's better o'rourke explaining why
it's okay to kill babies late in in the
term
so the question is about abortion and
reproductive rights and and my answer to
you is that that should be a decision
that the woman makes he knows his lines
and he knows what he is supposed to say
this is a radical position and Democrats
continue to maintain this radical
position even in opposition to their own
base because when every issue boils down
to an identity politics issue when it's
not about reasonable conversation about
the nature of human life and what is
happening inside the womb when it turns
into an attack on a political principle
I wish were true is an attack on me it's
very easy to get people to clap for you
like seals this is what bado is doing I
mean it's just warmed over Obama ISM
with a side dose of Hopi changing us
there's a piece in The Washington Post
about beta overwork today there's so
many pieces like this beta works early
campaign upbeat sentiments absent many
specifics so are they just now noticing
the guy has no specifics it's funny they
ignored that when he was running against
Ted Cruz but now they're suddenly
noticing oh look bait oh he doesn't know
things the former congressman from El
Paso quickly listed a few issues when he
was speaking to a group of women Sunday
afternoon and was asked to share his
vision for America and then he detailed
his vision for the campaign you ready
this is his vision for the campaign beta
O'Rourke
okay I'm going everywhere writing nobody
off taking no one for granted could care
less what party you belong to to whom
you pray or whether you pray at all who
you love how many generations you've
been here whether you just got here
yesterday we're gonna define ourselves
by our aspirations our ambitions and the
ability to bring this country together
the hell does that mean that held is
that how you're gonna bring the country
together around age around the set of
shared nothing around the set of shared
nothing I mean you literally just said
you don't care about anybody's identity
which is fine but then they have to be
united by something if they are not
united by something then they will be
divided by everything that is the way
diversity works if you are not united by
something you are divided by everything
else even the Washington Post says he
never got to articulating a clear vision
for America and he continues to maintain
this position that he doesn't actually
have to define what exactly he is
talking about and people fall for this
garbage Olga
in chess 70 who drove more than two
hours on Saturday from the Des Moines
suburb to Waterloo to seal work speak
said he's just so positive that's what I
like he's not saying straight Democrat
he's not saying independent he's not
saying just progressive he's not saying
no to Republican that's just it he
includes everyone I'm all for
inclusivity well this sounds very much
like the Obama campaign circa 2008
we're not runs late we're not blue split
what are the United States also I wish
were all blue spikes or work continues
to act like he is Gumby he seriously
talked about how he wants the public to
shape him okay so he actually says that
he wants the public to help him shape
himself help me help you
beta O'Rourke the fact that he's taken
seriously demonstrates the lack of good
ideas in in the in the left base the
ideal leader in the left base right now
the person who keeps throwing out ideas
to no avail his Elizabeth Warren she did
a big town hall event on CNN last night
and in that town hall event she just
kept throwing out more and more radical
proposals she suggested for example that
it was time to abolish the Electoral
College which obviously is a great idea
the colors of the wind man one of the
things that you love about Elizabeth
Warren is that she says that she is for
America's institutions being durable
enough to contain president Trump and
yet she wants to abolish the Electoral
College here she was yesterday talking
about abolishing the electoral college
don't come to places like Mississippi
yeah
they also come to places like California
and Massachusetts right because we're
not the battleground states well my view
is that every vote matters and the way
we can make that happen
is that we can have national voting and
that means get rid of the electoral
college there's something that mildly
opportunistic about this there are
arguments for getting rid of the
electoral college I actually hear those
arguments I think they're reasonable
arguments for it but the argument can't
be Trump won and that unfortunately is
the Democratic argument on this score
the electoral college has served America
pretty well and the fact is that if we
were to have a straight popular vote
there is no question that people who
live in the rural areas would certainly
feel a greater divide from people who
live in the cities because the fact is
that the cities would then dominate our
electoral politics nobody would get
campaign to and be everybody campaigning
in LA and New York and Washington DC and
Chicago and Dallas all of which wasn't
all great cities I mean I live in LA
I've been a city boy all my life but the
fact is if you want to help rural
divides be overcome that's probably not
the way to do it that wasn't the only
radical Elizabeth Warren proposal she
also said that she would think about
eliminating private insurance I liked
how Democrats are just like yeah I'll
think about this proposal to eliminate a
hundred and sixty-five million health
care plans it's worth considering well
maybe you should have considered it
before you enter the presidential race
lady you are a co-sponsor of senator
Bernie Sanders Medicare for all bill and
I understand there are a lot of
different paths to universal coverage
but his bill that you've co-sponsored
would essentially eliminate private
insurance is that something you could
support he's got a runway for that I
think we get everybody together and
that's what it is we'll decide we start
with our values we'll get to the right
place so theoretically though there
could be a role for private insurance
companies under President temporary role
it's a big and complex system and we've
got to make sure that we land this in a
way that doesn't do any harm everybody
has got to stay covered it's critical
okay so she has no solutions but she is
saying all the words that people want to
hear this is Elizabeth Warren stick
she's trying to steal Bernie Sanders his
base I don't think that it is going to
go where she wants it to go there's one
area where she believes that she can
make some hay and that is on the
intersectional theory area she believes
that she can move into Kamala Harris his
base if she pander is hard enough and so
she's been pushing slavery reparations
the impact
of discrimination handed down from one
to the next means that today in America
because of housing discrimination
because of employment discrimination we
live in a world where for the average
white family has $100 the average black
family has about five dollars so I
believe it's time to start the national
full-blown conversation about
reparations I mean come on come on it's
time to start the national but she will
not explain what exactly does
reparations should be should America
collectively be sorry for the for
slavery of course it was a historic sin
should I be sorry for slavery should you
be sorry for slavery well I didn't slave
anybody and nobody I know enslaved
anybody and none of my ancestors
enslaved anybody and I have not
benefited from slavery so I'm having a
hard time with the I'm supposed to pay
out of my own pocket to somebody who may
not even be the descendants of slaves if
this is simply race-based as opposed to
history based and again slavery ended in
the United States in 1865 if there's a
case for reparations the best case for
reparations is that people were
systemically harmed by Jim Crow and that
the people who specifically damage them
should pay them reparations but the case
for slavery reparations is obvious
political pandering by Elizabeth Warren
and all the other Democrats who are
pushing this sort of stuff again
focusing on what divides us as opposed
to what unites us because nobody
actually wants to talk about what unites
us because unfortunately for a lot of
people on the left and on the populace
right what divides us is more important
than what unites us okay so we're gonna
talk a little bit more about the
Democratic presidential candidates all
of whom are proposing vast institutional
changes to the nature of American
government but first we're gonna have to
go over to Daily wire calm and subscribe
for $9.99 a month you can get a
subscription to daily wire calm when you
do you not only get this show you also
get the rest of this show later two
additional hours of the Ben Shapiro show
so go check that out right now I think
that you are going to enjoy it we answer
questions sometimes during the actual
breaks so you can interact with me and
for $99 a year you also get this the
very greatest and beverage vessels
that's the annual subscription this
beverage vessel will give you strength
and intellectual fervor go check it out
right now the leftist years cut or
called tumblr today also at long last as
I have mentioned in my latest book the
right side of history
is officially released the book details
the crisis of purpose that is happening
right now in Western civilization so if
you want to know how we got here how we
get back on track head on over to Amazon
Barnes & Noble or right side of history
book calm to pick up your copy and tune
in tomorrow we have a special episode of
the conversation at 7 p.m. Eastern 4
p.m. Pacific we'll talk about all of
these issues I am sure go check that out
also make sure that you subscribe so
that you can get our Sunday specials on
Saturday our last Sunday special
featured dr. Phil and that came out
Saturday if you were a subscriber our
next Sunday special feature someone else
I won't tell you about until later this
week so go check it out right now
subscribe leave us a review of YouTube
in iTunes it always helps us we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so it's not just Elizabeth Warren trying
to push harder to the left in order to
shore up the the intersectional base as
well as the Bernie Sanders base or cut
into it it's also cory booker who's the
odd man out in this presidential cycle
he is just not polling and that's
because you look at Cory Booker and you
think this guy is overproduced he's just
over produced it's like an early Michael
Bay film everything is over done it's
it's a Transformers flick and you can
see all the gears moving just like in
the Transformers flick but here is cory
booker yesterday claiming that he wants
term limits for Supreme Court justice is
weird he didn't want that five minutes
ago but now that President Trump has
appointed two Supreme Court justices now
he wants term limits so that he can term
out people like Clarence Thomas
obviously I think we need to fix this in
court I think they stole the Supreme
Court seat can we keep it at nine should
we give it at nine I think I would like
to start exploring a lot of options and
we should have a national conversation
term limits for Supreme Court justices
might be one thing to give every
president to be ability to choose three
people holding on to those seats in ways
that I don't think is necessary healthy
so I want to favor limit look I think we
term limits might be a better way to
saying okay so he's saying term limits
obviously and that of course is
politically driven he wasn't talking
about term limits until five seconds ago
I've said that Supreme Court justices
may be term limits are a good idea I
said that for a very long time actually
I used to say that back all the way in
law school but all this newfound
institutional change that Democrats are
in favor of it's weird that it coincides
with President Trump ruling that's weird
that president from being the president
of the United States suddenly has
changed their view of our key
institutions well there are a couple of
other candidates who are coming out of
the woodwork Bill DeBlasio
still continues to run around suggesting
that he is a presidential candidate and
it really is kind of sad we actually
have some theme songs for four we have a
theme song for it for Bill DeBlasio we
haven't premiered yet
[Music]
yeah nobody likes Bill DeBlasio so he
was in Concord New Hampshire according
to the New York Post Mayor Bill de
Blasio's ongoing tease of a presidential
run didn't exactly pull in the crowds
during a campaign ESCA vents in the
Granite State only 20 people showed up
Sunday to hear the leader of America's
largest city hold a roundtable on mental
health including the 14 people on the
panel so six people showed up a full
half dozen I mean maybe they knew that
meeting with the groundhog killer was
actually a dangerous proposition
there were also six reporters on hand I
do love how the media operate there is a
reporter for every member of the crowd
for Bill DeBlasio de Blasio pulled a
well-worn page from his mayoral campaign
and he put lady
he put first lady chirlane McCray
centerstage on what was his second day
touring the crucial primary battleground
state
the day began with de Blasio Democrats
having her under scrutiny 1 billion
dollar Mental Health Initiative thrive
at New York City
de Blasio said she's my partner in
everything I do and that is a phrase we
say every opening and have said for
years they feel her humanity and they
feel her compassion I've never truly
understood why it is that first ladies
are considered political figures this
makes no sense to me they are not
elected if you want to elect Charlene
McRae then you know what you can do is
elect cherlene McRae but why you should
get a package deal with the wife's
political priorities when you elect the
husband or the other way around is
really bizarre to me it's really bizarre
but na in case bill de blasio
has no actual support for his run that's
not stopping him anyway because
everybody is interested in in running at
this point in one second we will get to
another one of the myriad Democratic
hands and it's this one a no-name who's
beginning to pick up a little bit of
steam we'll get to that in just one
second so there are a couple of no names
in this presidential race who have
picked up a little bit of steam
obviously Pete punishes from from South
Bend Indiana has picked up at least a
little bit of media coverage I don't
think he's picked up any popular steam
the other guy who's picked up some steam
is Andrew yang who seems to have a lot
of millennial appeal he also has
positions on every possible issue if you
go to his website Andrew yang it is just
filled with positions more positions
than the kamasutra just positions on
every possible issue we do have a theme
song for Andrew yang actually
so the only reason that we are using the
song is because he does have an
unfortunate habit of sounding off on
weird issues today is weird issue for me
Andrew yang he is taking a strong public
stance against circumcision because this
is what we need our presidential
candidates sounding off about is
circumcision now listen as an Orthodox
Jew I have a vested interest in the
continuation of the availability of
circumcision I will say that I find it
very odd that Democrats many Democrats
okay with chopping a baby's head off in
the womb not okay with chopping a little
bit off the tip of the penis right not
not okay with getting rid of the
foreskin which by the way does not
inhibit sexual function in any way as an
Orthodox Jew I'm circumcised I have been
ever - ever since I was eight days old
and you know what everything's working
just fine got two kids intent on making
more it's pretty fine everything's good
this is true by the way for the vast
majority of American men the majority of
American men are circumcised the Andrew
yang wants to stop all that he said in a
little notice tweet last week that he
was against the ritualized practice of
cutting a newborns foreskin he said that
in an interview with The Daily Beast he
would incorporate that view into public
policy mainly by pushing initiatives
meant to inform parents they don't need
to have their infants circumcised for
health reasons well that of course is
controversial it does lower rates of for
example penile cancer and the and the I
believe it it also lowers rates of
certain STD transmissions but it's
really funny all of Andrew yang says he
wants to top-down take on the medical
availability of circumcision I thought
that what why can't that be a decision
between the parents and their doctors so
it's a decision between a woman and her
doctor when she wants to kill a baby in
the womb it is not a decision between a
woman and her doctor' when she decides
whether to circumcise a baby which has
no significant after effects on children
in any way so well done Andrew yang it's
fascinating though he has picked up a
fair bit of support I have gotten a lot
of emails about having Andrew yang on
the program I'd be happy to have Andrew
yang on the Sunday special and we have
these Sunday specials I've invited I
believe every major Democratic
presidential candidate I invited Pete
Buddy shows on the on the actual on
Twitter on the Sunday special he said
he'd be interested never got
to us honestly if people ever watch the
Sunday special you will see that I'd
treat everybody on all sides of the
aisle with I think a fair bit of
generosity the same would be true of
Andrew yang I'd love to have Andrew on
the on the Sunday special we can discuss
all of this stuff nonetheless he is
developing a cult following he's
proposing a $1,000 a month freedom
dividend every adult in America and that
freedom dividend presumably is is not
going to be paid out as opposed to
welfare it'll be continuation of welfare
policies plus the $1,000 a month
freedom dividend if you were to propose
a universal basic income that was a
replacement for the welfare system I
think there's a strong argument for it
that looks a lot like the the negative
income tax proposed by Milton Friedman
three decades ago four decades ago but
if you are proposing it in addition to
the current welfare system we have in
the United States then all you're doing
is just adding more money on top of an
already failing system so his drawing
major crowds he outlined his idea to a
crowd of mostly Millennials and an
outdoor soccer field lined with food
trucks
apparently some 3,000 people showed up
to one of his recent rallies more than
66,000 donors have contributed over
$350,000 to the campaign this month only
1% of Democratic voters have expressed
support for him but he is available for
the debates so be interesting to see
what he has to say when he gets on that
debate stage again I will say that at
least Andrew yang has ideas as opposed
to beta or Oracle apparently has no
ideas at all he wants to eliminate
robocalling
he wants to increase public funding for
the arts and local newspapers he would
like to protect children from
smartphones presumably with legislation
he wants to pay college athletes which I
agree with he argues that the best way
to ensure wealthy people pay their fair
share of taxes is to impose a
value-added tax well that obviously is a
national sales tax as opposed to an
income tax I'm in favor of he
understands it is possible to have a
robust federal government that is not
overly wasteful or staffed by
bureaucratic layabouts this is according
to the week now all of that sounds
better than what the other Democrats are
talking about so we may make fun a
little bit love-tap Andrew yang but the
fact is that at least yang has some
ideas as opposed to some of these other
Democrats who are trotting out a bunch
of nonsense as I've said before of these
Democrats but erosion
are the most interesting to me there are
also people who have 1% of support so
maybe there's a correlation there
meanwhile yeah there's a lot of hubbub
today over president Trump going after
Kellyanne Conway's husband this has been
a long simmering debate and feud between
George Conway who's the lawyer husband
to Kellyanne Conway and president from
finally fired back at George Conway
because George Conway was tweeting out
that President Trump is nutso his own
curse and so President Trump tweeted
back a total is there today so rough day
for Kellyanne Conway he recently warned
George Conway said in a series of tweets
and retweets that Trump's erratic and
voluminous social media activity was a
sign that his mental condition was
getting worse
Kellyanne had said that she doesn't
share those concerns with her husband
I've said before guys that I think that
you do have to share some political
priorities not only with your neighbors
but presumably with your spouse it's got
to be kind of uncomfortable right to be
Kellyanne Conway at this point and have
your boss going after your husband
openly on social media
we've not a good by the way not a good
look for the President of the United
States don't punch down to George Conway
dude it just unnecessary unnecessary
people who think you're nuts already
think you're nuts and you going after
George Conway he's not doing you any
favors on on this score so yeah again
mr. president please just just stop I'm
happy to cover the Democrats day in and
day out but you're gonna have to stop
with this with the silly crap honestly
it makes you less popular not more
popular I know you think that that
people bought the ticket to ride the
train
well the train is going to have a short
stop in 2020 if you don't cut this sort
of nonsense out first of all you know
they at least at least you can say that
he's firing back at George Conway him
going after John McCain over the weekend
was just immoral so there's that alright
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like today there's a new movie on
Netflix and this movie is just
chock-full of stars it's Ben Affleck
Oscar Isaac Charlie Hunnam Garrett
Hedlund who's a shockingly good actor
actually and Pedro Pasco who you'll
recall from Game of Thrones and also
from narcos he's a terrific actor the
movie is about a bunch of soldiers who
decide that they are going to
essentially rob a drug cartel leader in
South America it's really good it's a
tight movie it's got a lot of moral
ambiguity to it which is
really interesting you can go check it
out right now it's called triple
frontier on Netflix here is a little bit
of the preview I have never had a
feeling as pure or proud as completing a
mission all you everything we've done
over the last 17 years trying to make a
difference and we never took a dime
you've been found for your country and
you can't even afford to send your kids
to college I got a job for you retired
fish I need a pilot I got the baby now
this can change you in that baby's life
forever we finally get to use our skills
for our own benefit dharak and it's
pretty intense and it's very stressful
it's definitely worth the watch there
there's some really good stuff about it
it's it's really well shot go check it
out triple frontier over in Netflix okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
so the thing that I hate number one they
always do these polls people always do
these polls where they ask people if
they want higher taxes on the rich
people and better welfare and people
shockingly are like yeah you know that'd
be great more free stuff for me and tax
you yeah you know why they say that
because it's fun to tax other people and
then take their crap that's that's
actually really easy this is one of the
reasons why I think that we had better
get back into the mode of you don't get
to take other people's money the mode of
every individual is made in the image of
God and that means you do not have a
right to other people's property but
it's always amusing to me when people
who are on the left end cite these polls
as evidence that people are in favor of
a more socialized system yeah they're in
favor of it until they realize the cost
of it it's very easy to believe that all
of the rich people have giant Scrooge
McDuck money bins in the backyard and
then if you just take those money bins
they'll continue to work just as hard
and that they will continue to employ
just as many people it's obvious
nonsense it's just not true
if you want to know how Singapore which
is legitimately a rock-like there's no
actual natural resources on Singapore
has become a powerful economy it's
because they don't actually believe in
taxing the living hell out of everybody
who's wealthy the same thing was true in
Hong Kong when it was run by the British
basically any safe haven for well that
ends up being a wealthy country this is
true in switzer
as well nonetheless they cite these
polls as evidence that this is what the
people want yeah you know what the
people then don't expect it you're going
to have to hike the middle-class taxes
it turns out the rich people don't have
enough money to pay everyone else their
salary and also pay for everybody else's
welfare programs not people said in this
poll of 2100 ECD countries the
industrialized countries that they were
not getting their fair share given what
they paid into the system people were on
average particularly concerned about
access to good quality affordable long
term care for the elderly housing and
health services weird because all of
these countries are the ones that we are
emulating so you're telling me all of
the OECD countries that we emulate want
even more welfare they're not even
satisfied with what they have now and in
places like Denmark they're paying 60%
taxes if you're middle class if you're
barely middle-class a great lie about
redistribution is that the
redistribution stops when you when you
get to the upper income levels it is
just not true it's just not real
somebody's gonna have to pay for all
this crap and it's going to be you okay
meanwhile other things that I hate so
representative Devin Nunez Republican of
California has now sued Twitter to
anonymous Twitter accounts and political
consultant Liz Maher for more than two
hundred and fifty million dollars he's
alleging that the defendants engaged in
negligence defamation per se insulting
words and civil conspiracy I'm not sure
that insulting words is a is a cause of
action in the suit Nunez accuses Twitter
of having a political agenda by allowing
two anonymous accounts 7:00 noon as his
mom and Devon Eunice's cow and Liz Maher
to attack defame and demean him the suit
alleges that the two Twitter accounts
engaged in a vicious defamation campaign
against Nunez that lasted for over a
year and claims that Mayer relentlessly
smeared and defamed him by filming
stunts at his DC office accusing him of
multiple crimes and filing fraudulent
ethics complaints against him the
lawsuit also claims to Twitter shadow
ban Nunez which restricted his free
speech and amplified the abusive and
hateful content now I think that this
lawsuit is probably improperly filed I
think it is difficult to win a
defamation lawsuit as a public figure
generally and you just have to take an
enormous amount of crap I mean it's a
public figure mmm
yeah presumably more public than 7:00
noon as I take an enormous amount of
abuse and garbage on social media that's
correct that just goes along with the
territory I've never once thought about
suing
detractors on Twitter for example with
that said the loud the loud outcry and
amusement of people at noonas from
people on the left people saying well
you know why is he so offended by
Twitter these are the exact same people
who say that Russian BOTS got Trump
elected using Twitter which of course
Twitter it's just something we're all
gonna have to live with and you're just
gonna have to deal with it or Twitter is
innately insanely powerful in which case
tenant Devin Nunes should be able to sue
people you got to pick one guys you
don't get to pick both so we're gonna be
back here a little bit later today with
much more we have a couple of guests on
later today I know David French from
national review is stopping by to
discuss a gun manufacturer lawsuit that
hit that must be taken up by the Supreme
Court basically a lower court just ruled
that gun manufacturers can be held
liable for the misuse of guns which is
an insane insane ruling we'll discuss
that with David French a little bit
later today on the show plus we'll have
you all the updates for you later today
you're listening to the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19